y ya me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero Jorge Hurtado para hablar de
economía Jorge bienvenido la presidenta
de la comisión europea Úrsula fonder ley
en presentó las líneas generales de su
plan Industrial Greenville de qué se
trata bueno esta iniciativa Busca
acelerar las impresiones en tecnologías
limpias y también en la transición
energética es importante decir que esta
ley sería la respuesta a la ley
estadounidense sobre el clima que Europa
considera como proteccionista y hacer
frente según ellos a los desafíos que
supone China y Estados Unidos se llama
plan Industrial con el cual según Busca
mantener el atractivo de la industria
europea para ser competitivos con las
ofertas de incentivos que existen
actualmente el plan haría que este
bloque adapte temporalmente sus normas
sobre ayudas estatales para hacerlas más
rápidas y sencillas sin descartar
incluso la exoneraciones el bloque Sería
más ágil para contrarrestar las críticas
comerciales desleales Según dicen vengan
de Washington o también incluso de China
actualmente a Europa le preocupa que la
ley estadounidense de reducción de la
inflación que incluye incentivos para
las empresas de energías renovables
discrimine a las empresas europeas y
lleve las inversiones solamente hacia
Estados Unidos bueno Jorge el foro
económico ayer pero hoy era el primer
día de programación oficial qué fue lo
que marcó la agenda bueno fuertes
declaraciones de Europa y también de
China luego de este acuerdo ecológico
que anunció la Unión Europea china
también reabrió sus puertas al mundo
según el discurso del Vice Primer
Ministro liuje quien dejó claro que el
país quiere que los inversores
extranjeros sean la clave en los
intentos de Beijing por reactivar su
economía la primera dama ucraniana
también dijo que entregaría una carta a
liu dirigida al presidente chino en la
que se exponen las propuestas del
presidente selenski para poner fin a la
guerra en su país Por otra parte la
directora gerente del fondo monetario
internacional cristalina georgiaba
afirmó que el crecimiento económico
mundial tocaría a fondo este año bueno
atravesamos el Atlántico vamos a México
porque se impuso un arancel del 50 por
ciento para la exportación de maíz bueno
el gobierno mexicano como en esta medida
Busca estabilizar los precios a nivel
interno del maíz a partir de este martes
17 de enero las exportaciones de maíz
blanco tendrán un arancel del 50 por
ciento el decreto publicado el lunes en
el diario oficial de la federación que
estará vigente hasta el 30 de junio de
este año el maíz blanco es esencial en
la dieta de los mexicanos representa el
89% de la producción total de granos de
ese país varios estudios inclusive
señalan que los mexicanos consumen más
de 330 kilogramos de maíz blanco por
persona al año eso Es aproximadamente
unas 732 libras anteriormente no había o
no existía un arancel a las
exportaciones mientras que las
importaciones quedaron libres de
impuestos México Al igual que la mayoría
de países está luchando contra el
aumento generalizado de los precios y
ahora vamos a Chile que se convierte en
el primer país de América Latina en
incluir la biodiversidad en la economía
bueno Esto con la creación del comité de
capital natural esto es un organismo que
considera la biodiversidad como parte de
la estructura económica de ese país el
presidente Gabriel Boris firmó el
decreto un día antes de la reunión del
comité de ministerio donde van a votar
el polémico proyecto portuario minero
Dominga que según algunos expertos ponen
riesgo la reserva nacional pingüino de
Humboldt el comité discutirá cambios en
el diseño de políticas públicas y
decisiones de fomento de inversión que
incorporen este criterio ambiental en
las decisiones el principal objetivo
será asesorar al presidente de la
República en la medición la valoración
la protección la restauración y también
el mejoramiento del capital natural en
Chile en ese país el 21% de la
superficie es territorio protegido y el
43% de las áreas marinas son zonas
económicas exclusivas con ciertas
normativas específicas para proteger la
biodiversidad y vamos a cerrar con el
anuncio de Microsoft que informó que va
a recortar miles de puestos de trabajos
y algunas funciones en las divisiones de
recursos humanos y también en ingeniería
bueno esta decisión se suma a la de
otras grandes en el sector tecnológicas
Como por ejemplo meta y empresas como
Amazon que continúan despidiendo según
la cadena británica Sky news Microsoft
Planet recortar alrededor del 5% de su
planilla es decir unos 11.000 puestos
los recortes serán significativamente
mayores que en otras rondas del año
pasado según informó bloomberg la
empresa tenía 221.000 empleados
contratados a tiempo completo 122 mil de
ellos En Estados Unidos y 99.000 en
escala internacional Microsoft tiene la
presión de mantener el crecimiento en su
unidad de nube azure después de varios
trimestres de desaceleración en el
mercado de las computadoras
nosotros Seguimos aquí en directo
América con directo
[Música]